ci raccontiamo ogni giorno quanto è
bello il nostro paese quanto ci piace
vivere in italia quanto l'italia uno dei
paesi più belli al mondo ci raccontiamo
quanto la moda quanto le l'arte quanto
tutto ciò che vediamo intorno a noi ci
piace che piaccia al mondo
bastano alla mattina a fare un giro in
qualsiasi centro storico in italia in
una qualsiasi campagna per vedere la
bellezza del nostro paese la bellezza
incredibile unica al mondo quello che
spesso ci dimentichiamo è che quella
bellezza è fatta da alcuni talenti che
l'hanno creata alcuni pittori alcuni
scultori alcuni creativi registi
qualsiasi essi siano che ogni giorno con
la loro passione con la loro voglia di
fare hanno creato quelle cose bellissime
che vediamo intorno a noi senso alcuni
famosissimi ce ne sono alcuni che spesso
neanche ricordiamo il nome si sono
tramandati nell'epoca ma quello che è
rimasto è sempre la loro voglia di
cambiare la situazione attuale del
provare a migliorarla del provare a
trasformare quella loro passione in
qualcosa di concreto che impattasse non
solo su se stessi ma soprattutto su
tutti gli altri
su tutto il resto del mondo oggi siamo
una fase di down del nostro paese una
fase di crisi basta aprire un qualsiasi
giornale per leggere la crisi economica
la crisi di valore le crisi religiose
quanto tutto vada anche male e questo fa
sì che spesso ci chiudiamo in noi stesse
non guardiamo più cosa c'è intorno a noi
quello che sta avvenendo però è un
rinascimento del digitale siamo in una
fase in cui grazie alla tecnologia
ognuno di noi può provare a costruire il
proprio futuro
quello che accade e che grazie degli
strumenti semplici con poche barriere
all'ingresso noi riusciamo a costruire a
migliorare tutto ciò che abbiamo intorno
che siano i mestieri più tradizionali
quindi che hanno fatto la storia del
nostro paese con una manifattura
intelligente che sennò piattaforme
totalmente online che permettono di
connettere persone oggetti qualsiasi
esse siano abbiamo la possibilità nelle
nostre mani di cambiare cosa sta
succedendo intorno a noi
i leader di questo cambiamento che non è
italiano ma mondiale e globale
li conosciamo bene sono volti noti sono
coloro che grazie all'unione del
digitale della tecnologia del provare a
cambiare ciò che vedono intorno a loro
provano a cambiarlo costruendo non più
semplicemente degli oggetti delle cose
ma delle aziende delle cose che cambiano
impattano su ognuno di noi sono i nuovi
talenti non solo solamente
internazionale massimo ha parlato prima
ce ne sono tantissimi altri che stanno
costruendo le cose che sono molto anche
riconosciute a livello internazionale
perché stanno tramite la tecnologia
impattando su tutto il mondo dalla
manifattura intelligente al mondo della
salute al mondo della moda al mondo
della musica mondi che sono stati nostri
che sono stati e sono nati in un paese
come l'italia che spesso oggi si stanno
a distanza ne stanno scappando
all'estero
il tema è negli ultimi cinque seicento
anni ci sono sempre state un aiuto
concreto a questi talenti che nascevano
se pensiamo alle corti dei mecenati che
avvicinavano emettevano intorno a loro i
migliori talenti di quel periodo i
migliori creativi migliori artisti le
persone che potevano aiutare loro stesso
ai loro mecenati ma che soprattutto
stando vicini creavano dei giardini dei
luoghi in cui si autoalimenta vano e
questo faceva sì che ognuno di loro
crescesse migliorasse se stesso nello
stare vicino agli altri perché non c'era
qualcuno dall'alto che insegnava ma
ognuno insegnava agli altri ognuno
insegnando agli altri crea cresceva mi
si migliorava e creava delle cose
meravigliose che oggi vediamo tutti i
giorni nel settecento nell'ottocento
c'erano i caffè letterari dei posti dove
gli artisti gli scrittori si
incontravano beviamo un caffè ma
soprattutto discutevano parlavano
cambiavano e scambiamo idee tra di loro
il novecento il nostro paese è stato
reso grande da quei distretti
industriali che si verticalizza vano e
aiutavano e permettevano le diverse
aziende in determinati settori di
aiutarsi di crescere insieme del creare
una filiera e di essere rilevante a
livello internazionale sono luoghi
che hanno sempre però delle
caratteristiche il mettere vicino alle
persone in modo fisico perché soltanto
con una partita a biliardino non
soltanto uno scambio di idee per quanto
focoso adesso sia che si possono possono
nascere nuove idee nuove cose nuove
passioni una selezione perché bisogna
lavorare sui migliori su quelli che
possono davvero cambiare le cose
mettendoli vicino mettendoli a contatto
auto selezionando c non ci deve essere
qualcuno dall'alto che dica cosa fare
devono essere le persone che si auto
selezionano e devono essere uno stesso
settore perché la vicinanza di idee e di
passioni permette l'ora davvero di
crescere insieme di aiutarsi di creare
cose meravigliose
oggi non ci sono più i mecenati ce ne
sono molto pochi
ci sono pochi i caffè letterari si sono
ancora qualche distretto anche se molto
in crisi perché forse perché oggi è
cambiato come sono quali sono i nuovi
creativi quelli che stanno impattando
davvero sul mondo
queste sono persone che si uniscano ai
core king nei luoghi della condivisione
sono dei luoghi fisici che permettono a
coloro che oggi lavorano con un computer
di costruire il loro futuro di avere gli
strumenti che non è oltre a una
connessione internet è un posto dove
stare
perché è vero che ognuno di noi tutti i
giorni lavorano online con persone
all'altra parte del mondo e basta skype
basta qualsiasi strumento di connessione
per lavorare insieme ma quando siamo
vicini quando torniamo a quel caffè
quando torniamo a quella stretta di mano
sappiamo che è lì che nascono le cose
più belle le idee più vere
i momenti migliori quello che ne abbiamo
provato a fare è stato proprio questo e
dire cos'è che oggi può permettere di
far stare insieme alle persone di
talento di valore che gli permetta di
credere in questo paese perché è inutile
che ci lamentiamo di un paese che va
male se non proviamo ad aiutare chi
questo paese lo sta provando a creare se
non gli diamo gli strumenti per poter
crescere e per potersi sviluppare che
non è qualcosa dall'alto di
finanziamenti pubblici attività di
questo tipo sono cose semplici sono
quella contaminazione naturale che si
crea nel mettere insieme persone che
fanno cose simili che sono animati dalla
passione del farle siamo di brescia e
siamo partiti
anni fa dalla nostra piccola città una
città con una grandissima forza
imprenditoriale con una grandissima nel
dna inserito ormai di tutte le persone
ma forse una città oggi più in crisi e
abbiamo provato a creare un luogo fisico
che contenesse queste persone che gli
desse quelle basi di strumenti per poter
realizzare le loro passioni per poter
trasformare le loro passioni nelle loro
attività
e questo lo facciamo dandogli uno spazio
fisico un banale ufficio una scrivania
una cosa fisica dove possano stare
vicino tutti i servizi tutte le cose di
cui possono aver bisogno per essere
focalizzati sul loro business
ma soprattutto li commettiamo con il
mondo e con loro stessi perché crediamo
che oggi il business non possa più
essere locale e qualsiasi idea parte
debba da subito essere pensata globale
quindi una rete di partner una rete di
spazio in giro per il mondo ti permette
di rimanere locale non scappare dal tuo
territorio che quello che troppo spesso
avviene i giovani oggi prendono vanno
vanno a londra quando san francisco sono
animati dal pensare che solo in questi
ecosistemi si possa fare quando invece
si può rimanere a casa propria ma
bisogna essere connesse a livello
mondiale di questi talenti l'italia è
veramente piena in questi tre anni
quando tre anni fa siamo partiti ne
abbiamo scoperti tantissimi gli style
sono due ragazzi che fotografi
bravissimi che abbiamo scoperto quasi
per caso nella nostra città erano
davvero in uno scantinato di una zona
secondaria di brescia e facevano delle
fotografie che erano famosi in tutto il
mondo firmavano copertine di magazine di
riviste ma nel loro territorio nel loro
paese
nessuno li conosceva perché erano
verticali facevano il loro lavoro lo
facevano benissimo forse troppo bene
nessuno li riconosceva nessuno li
aiutava non erano mai riusciti ad
emergere nella loro città nel loro
territorio che quella cosa che ti dà la
forza perché quando ti svegli la mattina
per quanto puoi aver fatto qualsiasi
raggiunto qualsiasi successo
professionale ma le persone intorno a te
non ti conoscono non ti danno quel
valore aggiunto e tu sei da solo per
quanto bravo
dopo un po ti spegne diventi una piccola
fiamma che non c'è più e quindi aveva
sono entrati all'interno di tag altre
persone come almir ammira viene da una
storia imprenditoriale di successo ma
aveva fatto questa piattaforma che
permetterà di prenotare i ristoranti la
cosa più semplice forse più banale con
la tecnologia era riuscito a fare ha
costruito una storia che proprio qualche
settimana fa
tripadvisor una grandissima azienda
americana è venuta e ha comprato come
leader italiano è oggi diventato manager
di questa multinazionale sull'italia e
quello che è stato bello è vedere la sua
storia da due persone poi non sono
entrati a crescere ea svilupparsi la in
più di 15 quando poi li hanno acquistati
in meno di un anno e mezzo una crescita
una velocità che nasceva proprio da
quella contaminazione continua che si
crea tra persone di queste di questo
settore ma ci essere capiti a 15 anni a
15 anni gli hanno regalato a 9 un kit di
elettronica ea 15 ha costruito la prima
stampante 3d vuole portare le stampanti
3d sul mercato consumer e sta costruendo
una stampa né da 300 euro per far sì che
ognuno sia una cosa accessibile a
chiunque a 15 anni
sono storie incredibili non solo per il
talento di queste persone ma perché
spesso non le conosciamo perché spesso i
media ci parlano ogni giorno di quanto
l'italia vada male e non esalta queste
storie bellissime di un paese che cambia
di un paese bello di un paese che eco è
riconosciuto è conosciuto a livello
internazionale per le sue eccellenze e
lasciamo queste eccellenze totalmente da
sole totalmente nel loro piccolo nella
loro stanza nel loro azienda nella loro
attività e non facciamo sistema non
cerchiamo di aiutarli e quello che è
accaduto quando provi a fare una cosa
questo tipo quando provi a mettere delle
storie insieme e non ad aiutarli
dall'alto perché non eravamo dall'alto
ne eravamo ragazzi che anche noi
facevamo questa attività è che
semplicemente credevamo di avere bisogno
per noi stessi di contaminarci di
crescere insieme agli altri perché non
c'è qualcuno che oggi ti possa insegnare
devi essere tu che vai e cerchi le tue
informazioni dagli altri quella
contaminazione che si crea nel lavorare
insieme forse la cosa che ti fa crescere
di piu e quello che è successo è stata
una cosa bellissima
perché una serie di amici una serie di
persone da tutta europa ci hanno detto
vogliamo replicare questa storia
crediamo che costruire un luogo di
questo tipo
possa impattare possa migliorare la
nostra città perché non esisterà più un
unico centro della creatività come forse
accadeva a 500 anni fa con firenze che
le grandi città che conosciamo questa
innovazione age diffusa non chiede il
permesso in qualsiasi posto e quindi
hanno detto possiamo replicare questa
cosa nel nostro territorio perché
vogliamo impattare e quello che è
accaduto e che 10 persone si sono messe
insieme e hanno creato dieci campus di
tallinn garden in giro per l'europa
facendo oggi non dieci singoli luoghi
come spesso avviene per in
italia vuol farsi il suo vuole provare a
costruirsi il suo coworking il suo
spazio con una bella vede una bella idea
prova a copiarla in questo caso è
successo una cosa meravigliosa
queste persone si sono messe insieme ha
detto prendiamo un modello che già
funziona e proviamo replicarlo nel
nostro territorio perché crediamo che il
valore del network si sa unire più punti
insieme unire più filosofia insieme non
creiamo semplicemente 10 coworking in
giro per l'europa ma creiamo il più
grande per nell'innovazione in italia e
in europa
seconda cosa che è successo e che
abbiamo selezionato su questi territori
più di 500 persone 500 persone che si
occupano di tecnologia che si occupano
di innovazione che si occupano di
creatività i più diversi e gli abbiamo
detto se vuoi c'è un posto dove puoi
stare c'è un posto dove puoi far
crescere la tua azienda dove puoi far
crescere la tua professione ciò che stai
facendo
e questo non è semplicemente un entrare
in uno spazio di lavoro condiviso non
credere che poi il territorio si possa
cambiare che io voglio crescere e
contaminarmi con il resto del mondo e
questo ha fatto sì che oggi non abbiamo
semplicemente 10 campus per quanto belli
per quanto studiato i dieci giardini ma
abbiamo soprattutto 500 piante che
dentro questi talent garden vivono ogni
giorno cresca non si sviluppa e lavorano
nei diversi spazi contaminandosi perché
quello che avviene che io possa rimanere
a brescia
posso rimanere sul mio territorio ma nel
momento in cui devo sviluppare il mio
progetto la mia attività dall'altra
parte del mondo a barcellona a milano o
da qualsiasi altro punto ho un posto che
mi aiuta a farlo ma non ho soltanto uno
spazio fisico una community di persone
che mi aiuta chi è interessato perché
perché siamo vicini
perché abbiamo le stesse idee perché
siamo riuniti dalla stessa passione e
diventa un acceleratore naturale di idee
e di passioni di competenze ma
soprattutto di attività perché oggi i
nuovi creativi i nuovi imprenditori non
sono più semplicemente dei creativi ma
se non soprattutto degli imprenditori
delle persone che prendono in mano il
loro futuro e provano a costruirselo e
in un momento in cui l'italia va male
non chiedono il permesso non dicono come
faccio a fare tutto va male e si
deprimano a questa cosa ma cercano di
costruirsi la costruiscono aziende
questo avendo progetti cambiando le cose
che come noi oggi le conosciamo comunque
l'ingrediente magico la tecnologia che
noi crediamo essere trasversale a
qualsiasi settore ed essere la cosa che
davvero ti permette di cambiare abbiamo
scritto 530 talenti in italia li
aiutiamo il tema non è aiutare loro
perché ne dall'alto possiamo aiutarli il
tema è siamo tutti i talenti
il tema è semplicemente lavorare insieme
provare a fare un pochino più sistema
perché in questo modo non cresciamo solo
noi ma cresce tutto il sistema è tutta
l'italia rendendolo ancora più bella è
la vera bellezza dell'italia grazie